Donald Trump has never done anything  halfway least of all as a parent my dad  is a natural-born encourage er the last  person who will ever tell you to lower  your sights or give up your dream I  always look forward to introducing him  to my friends especially the ones with  preconceived notions because they meet a  man with natural charm and no facade in  person my father is so friendly so  considerate so funny and so real my  friends walk away with a glimpse of all  that he is and all that he means to me  of the strong protective kind endearing  man I am so proud to call my father  I have admired my father all of my life  and I love him with all my heart god  bless you and thank you